thank you let's bring in west virginia
democratic senator joe manchin
from capitol hill senator thank you for
being here
good to be with you brett how are you
i'm great listen we want to talk about
what peter just talked about about crime
and the back and forth on all of that
but
i want to talk about the legislation
that's coming up and that is
this week there was a lot of back and
forth about
whether president biden was going to
sign a bipartisan infrastructure bill
if it didn't wasn't tied to a
reconciliation bill much bigger down the
road
there's now word that moderate democrats
are saying that maybe that
reconciliation bill can go forward but
can only be one trillion dollars or less
is that true well i don't know what the
size of the reconciliation bill will be
first of all uh brett there was never a
doubt in my mind that
that president biden didn't support the
bipartisan
infrastructure we'll call it traditional
infrastructure roads bridges
water and all the different things that
we have done this is the greatest
largest bill that we've ever done in
infrastructure in history united states
it has something for everybody and every
state needs so much help in this and
my state has one of the worst bridges
bridge situations in the country and
we desperately need them we need roads
repaired we need roads built
so it's good for everybody so with that
i never doubted that he would not
support it
he made a mistake when he spoke he
corrected that mistake
and we're moving forward and he's out
now not only
did he correct his mistake he's out now
supporting it and going full
full blast so i appreciate it saying
that he's going to go
he wants the bipartisan bill of course
but he's also saying he wants to sign
a bigger reconciliation bill this is
what nancy pelosi has said about all of
this
let me be really clear on this we will
not
take up a bill in the house
until the senate passes the bipartisan
bill
and an emphasis and a reconciliation
bill
that seems pretty clear from the speaker
of the house
for for you what does a reconciliation
bill have to look like
and are you alone in what you're
thinking about it
well brett i don't know about i've been
alone for a long time it seems like here
recently but what i will say is this
reconciliation i i am i
understand we'll probably have to go to
reconciliation because
uh i did not vote for the 2017 tax
the tax bill that president trump put
forward i had worked for a long time in
a bipartisan way with my republican
colleagues and friends
and democrats and we thought we had a
good bipartisan bill
for tax overhaul but at the end they
went to reconciliation and no democrats
were there
and i thought it was weighted uh too uh
too much to the
to the high-end earners if you will with
that um
i'm i'm agreeable to making adjustments
to the tax code which i think will be
fair and competitive i use the word
competitive
brett because we are in a global market
we're in a world global market here that
we have to compete
and with that you can't go just though
caution to the win
so what we're going to do is look at all
the rates that we think can be adjusted
and a competitive rate let's see how
much money that would spin off
and then based on what money we have to
spend our priorities on what we should
do
and then what we call a human
infrastructure bill
also brett i i remind everybody that we
put out close to six trillion dollars
in money in so many various ways
education
helping people medicaid assistance
extensions
of food programs we're doing an awful
lot we have done an awful lot
so all that should be taken into
consideration also what's been
accomplished but
with that we have 28.5 trillion dollars
of debt and i've said this before we are
writing checks our ca
our children could never cash and we're
putting let me try this
a different way if the reconciliation
bill they're envisioning
on the progressive side is four to six
trillion you're not going with that i
don't think i could ever get there to
that i don't think that we
i don't not unless we just throw caution
to the wind on the tax code and could
care less
are we competing in a global market and
are we being fair
uh that you just throw that out the
window
that seems to me this uh totally out of
the ballpark
you've always said here on this show
other shows that
uh you're you're against changing the
filibuster rules
but there is nuance there because
previous nuclear options have been
changed by
by changing the senate precedent um
not the rules so so are you for lowering
the lowering the threshold at all
from 60 votes to 55 votes we're changing
that in any way
brett i haven't changed at all on that
i've been at 60 votes i think basically
users change the attitudes of people and
we should be working together
there if the with the democrats are in
minority
and the republicans the majority we
should be able to find
10 at least 10 reasonable if it's a 50
50. and if they had 54 or 55 then you
only need five
to get to 16. so the bottom line is is
the filibuster is there so the minority
has input
i've been in the minority and i've been
in the majority and i can tell you when
you're in a minority
you'd like to have input if it was going
to be a 51 vote threshold basically just
a simple majority then i would have ran
for the house i wouldn't run for the
senate the senate is different
we have a different role to play and
basically we're called the most
deliberate body
for a reason we do deliberate we don't
expect anything
to come from the house that's going to
be in a bipartisan manner brett
we know it's going to be hot as a
firecracker we've got to cool that thing
off
well if we're no different the house
it'll come hot
come in hot and it'll go out hot that's
not what americans and christians
kiersten cinema from arizona has said
something similar and i think there are
other
people who maybe haven't spoken out uh
who may feel the way that you do
just privately seeing that there are a
lot of people
republicans i talked to say what would
it take for joe manchin to switch
parties
well if a party if if switching a party
whether you have a d
by your name an r by your name changes
who you are as a person
then you're in the wrong profession and
it's all about you and not about
the oath you take to the office the oath
to the constitution
to protect and defend that shouldn't be
a party affiliation that should be all
of us
i i've always said this brett i'm
fiscally responsible and socially
compassionate
i guess you can put me anywhere you want
but having the d
or an r by my name or changing and going
from one to another
i've never considered that i believe in
the democratic principles
that i grew up with and how i was raised
and i believe to respect
every one of my republican friends
because they
have they have a commitment and i
respect that and we sit down
and we talk we find out once we do we
agree on
the problem if the problem is something
that we can all agree on
then you can find a solution the hard
part today
is we can't even get agreement on the
facts anymore everybody brings their own
set of facts
to the table i said you're entitled to
your opinion
just don't bring your own set of facts
to support your opinion
in light of this is the pushback to that
they say
president biden didn't didn't win a
single county in west virginia
and you feel more allegiance if you're
getting pushed from democrats to do
something to the people of west virginia
or to the democratic party
well i'm here because of west virginia
i'm here because of every person in west
virginia
i love my state as much as anything in
the world
not quite as much as my family but not
far behind but
i i would do anything for my state of
west virginia it's been so good to me
the opportunities i've had a chance to
serve as governor for two terms
secretary of state before that house of
delegates state senate
i know this process very well these are
good people
and the bottom line is they have changed
i've told the democratic party
uh what had happened to people like west
virginians or people that come from
rural areas
that they right all of a sudden find
themselves not good enough
not clean enough not green enough and
not smart enough
well i'm sorry this is the same good
west virginians and independents and
republicans
that we've always been they just started
voting differently
for that reason but and they still send
me back to represent them and i do the
best that i possibly can
i know they don't know me as the
democrat joe the democrat
they know me as joe well you've been
successful as a democrat west virginia
last thing quickly will congress ever
care about the national debt again
and when you know brett i'm concerned
about this i don't see either side
i don't see either side i'll be honest
with you they all talk a good game
but there's no one no one truly
concerned about all the trust funds we
have the highway trust
all the different things medicare
medicaid you have social security
what are we doing are we at least
setting down and thinking
how are we able to basically continue
these programs that are so desperately
needed but also making sure
live with it we live within our means we
had a balanced budget amendment in west
virginia
most states have a balanced budget
amendment as governor i said
every week and then when the crash
happened in two eight and two nine
it was every day making adjustments so
we can live within our means
and when you get outside of your means
and you get my my grandfather would
always tell me
brett he said joe uncontrolled debt
unmanaged debt will make cowards out of
the decisions you'll make
you'll make cowardly decisions and we
are making cowardly decisions
because we will not face the truth of
basically a
situation that we have with unimaginable
debt
debt 28.5 trade hey brett
4 billion every day like clockwork i get
a wake-up call every morning
4 billion every day it increases yeah
and if interest rates go up one point we
pay more on the national
good the interest rates on more than we
pay for the pentagon
uh senator joe manchin thank you so much
for the time you're welcome back anytime
sure brett it's always good to be with
you hope you all as well and hope the
family's well
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else